but in this whole world turns you on
challenge I really just I just love I
love it you know I love being told no it
just means yes no to you yeah I turned
you off lack of enthusiasm really turns
me off originally when I brought the
script to them they were fairly
enthusiastic about it the one thing they
were not enthusiastic about was me
playing the part and and I really can't
blame them at the time Ryan O'Neal
I was a candidate Burt Reynolds Robert
Redford Jimmy Caan and they all you know
were at the top of their game so I could
see it but there was something inside of
me that that you know this opportunity
is never gonna come around and I really
wasn't used to money and I had no idea
of what I would be missing but the
temptation started to come forward first
it was twenty five grands and $100,000
of my I never heard of a hundred
thousand because I had had like $160 in
the banking like I said I had to sell my
dog and things were not looking very
very good my $40 car had just blown up
so I was taking a bus to work I'm just
still it didn't matter I wanted to stick
with it then it went up to 150,000
hundred seventy five thousand went up to
250 thousand now my head was starting to
spin and it went up to three hundred
thirty thousand and probably I heard it
well to three hundred sixty thousand and
I thought alright you know you've really
managed poverty very well you just
watched two amazing clips from Sylvester
Stallone take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]